do you still have that first picture of
my first person with Ozzy was Jim took
it it was 1997 it was I induced I found
some of those old like the old film but
do you still have that first photo yeah
oh you do okay yeah definitely somewhere
that's when we found him in their
bathroom look at his penis yeah yeah but
Jim got me into the into photos that's
not that's not up you know now as he's
like requesting gym for like gigs and
stuff he's like oh I need a comedian to
interview me obviously it should be
Norton do you think he knows that the
first interaction you guys followed him
into a bathroom to look at his penis I
don't know if he knows that you know cuz
i did on Ozzy's boneyard do a show over
there I had that in one of my promo yeah
that I follow him in the bathroom you
know to see his Pete look at his penis
so I he probably it might be out there
might be on his radar
yeah do you have you ever talk to him
about that I don't think so no you would
thou sure yeah I mean I think he
probably at this point get a kick out of
it
why to meet him though like we just met
him he was nice to us we got pictures
with him and we're just wait he was
doing like was a Total Request Live some
Russian guy
Misha or something I don't remember and
then and then we just and then
afterwards he was nice to us we took
pictures we talked to him for a couple
minutes we file had a follow him in
their bathroom after like it was like he
was blowing us off or go hey let's try
to get the pic we've already got
everything everything everything
everything picture head shake nice a
dragon Sabbath fans thank you they okay
I appreciate super nice but you couldn't
leave it alone couldn't leave it alone
and you're like oh now we have the
opportunity to see what his penis looks
like and I know he knew he looked over
he's like let's [ __ ] these guys you
gotta be kidding me
I just gave you some part of my time
celebrity and then they're like when you
see celebrities like not signing there
go they're such dicks
no they're not dicks it's because they
sign for people and they give him
everything and everybody people still
want more they want to go and follow him
into a bathroom but look at their dick
you were scary and he hugged a urinal
too cuz he felt he knew telling
someone's trying to look cuz remember he
was like pretty far away from the urinal
peon and then he saw us and he looked
over and then he [ __ ] and then he
hugged it Wow do you remember him how
can you no but I believe it I remember
it David Leroy I did that the David Lee
Roth
yeah I try to look at his mule to the of
the eternal because I was just hanging
with him in the VIP section of Rover
said hello and then he wouldn't have
followed him in there - you wanted to
see yeah they must know probably yet I
do so like I really have some open
microfauna in the bathroom and he's
trying to like know about what I went to
I would do one picture I wish I had I
didn't look at the penises though I went
to Wrestlemania one year and I was in
like a box where a whole bunch of the
legends were it was a giant Stadium and
I pissed
there was three journals and it was when
P Diddy was performing so everybody -
pissed at the same time and I went and
the urinals were Ric Flair me and the
Iron Sheik wow I was between the two of
them and in my head I was like I wish
somebody just had a picture of the back
of our head just all of us pissing sure
but it never occurred to me I need to
pop over this wall and take a look at
what these guys are working yeah I would
like to see what the Sheik is is as
workable you would I'm gonna guess he's
not as big as East by about a six he
says Ted nice line pi/6 and it's got
good girth you think so yeah the Archie
president girly penis when did you grow
out of trying to look at your like
celebrity idols penises I probably
haven't it's rare you're not answering
with him though that's the only problem
yeah I probably had probably stay even
if somebody was coming up - you're gonna
call I'm a fan of yours you're a fan of
mine we're talking about live to go to
the bathroom Oh funny thing me too yeah
I don't know I yeah you know I don't
know what it is it's not like a gay
thing for me like no I don't think it's
sexual curiosity I just curiosity your
wonder I'm like David Lee Roth that dick
has been in so many girls I want to see
what it looks like that was my theory
going in that makes sense you couldn't
see it now he hugged it - we knew I used
knew I was hovering
[Laughter]